qué bien tenía curiosidad por saber qué
tan rápido crece el pelo se afeitó la
cabeza e hizo un seguimiento del largo
del cabello aquí debería ser el perdón
en la siguiente tabla se muestra la
longitud de pelo de kevin según el
número de semanas que pasaron desde que
se la afecto es proporcionar la relación
entre el número de semanas y la longitud
del pelo de kevin bueno pues este que
viene está loco y decide tomar medidas
extremas para averiguar qué tan rápido
crece su pelo pero bueno de la primera a
la segunda semana hay un cambio de una
semana y pasa a medir 6 séptimos de
centímetros a un centímetro con 4
séptimos un centímetro con 4 séptimos es
lo mismo que pues uno es 7 entre 7 así
que 74 es 11 serían 11 séptimos así que
hay un cambio en la longitud de 5
séptimos de centímetros ahora de la
segunda a la tercera semana de nuevo hay
un cambio de una semana pero el cambio
en la longitud de su pelo es de 11
séptimos a 2 con un séptimo 2 con un
séptimo de 7 por 2 14 + 1 15 15 séptimos
tanto hay un cambio de 4 séptimos en la
longitud de su pelo aquí era de 5
séptimos y acá es de 4 séptimos por lo
tanto la relación no puede ser
proporcional